identity in cyberspace everyone is
identity you have an identity you make
it you create it in an interplay in an
online group of people within a small
group environment you express your
identity by what you say and how you say
it I think of it in a way that I think
about poker both poker and jury process
play around a round table with people
who are legally equal the poker
tournament starts with everyone having
the same number of chips and the actual
unfolding of the game not being so
structured that you can tell how it's
going to come out unless you actually
indulge the interplay of the players
your play will affect my play as mine
will affect yours and in a discussion
what I assert what I listen to the
strength with which i asserted so
willingness with which I take your point
these are elements of play poker breaks
down into how frequently you play what
games you choose to enter and once
you've chosen to enter how aggressively
you play one form
poker player is very cautious about
entering chooses battles very carefully
but when a battle is undertaken its
waged with assertiveness on the other
end of the spectrum it's possible to be
somebody who kind of has something to
say about everything let's see what this
hand produces but doesn't actually
commit very much and so doesn't risk
very much well out of that balance play
your identity as understood by the
others around the table take shape and
your force is experienced by the others
in how you express